[Music]
that's an acceleration throw
he
either let go of him or do a real
pin same acceleration
thr
[Music]
again a real
pin or let go of him
[Music]
he
the arm the arm the arm the arm the arm
is isolated take the arm
right clear the
line clear the
line
it's a push another acceleration
throw same thing that's an acceleration
throw
let's say this is UK's
spine okay and here's the
mat and
usually what you were doing is you're
kind of let's say there center of
gravity is here you're you're
accelerating
it in One Direction so if this is the
the head there's the nose you accelerate
it to the the front so you get like a
little tilt maybe you're here and then
you
accelerate that center of
gravity and then what happens is that
the the UK gets
lazy and it's more of a convenience so
it's a little more difficult to get
their feet back
underneath so they get that upright
posture again
and then but so what they do instead is
they leave their feet there and they let
just from from their will to leave their
feet
there eventually this acceleration of
this center of gravity here they just
decide for convenience sake to take a
Topsy Turvy effect do you see so they
they did it because as you pay
attenion in the acceleration from here
you get some little tilt going there is
no Topsy Turvy energy in the throat
there's no energy working on the head
and no energy working on the
feet and then at the same
time there's no
uh let's say spiraling of this of the
center through space the center is still
just traveling sagittally across the map
it it itself is not
turning
okay we'll do that last one you did okay
so when I come around here here is that
tilt of your body you see okay and then
you just
accelerate you see
that got it okay okay now use your
athleticism that we train and just run
out of
[Music]
it every single
time so
somewhere I have to start to add
differences so instead of cutting here
I'm going to start to rotate this this
way you see
and as I do that my body is going to go
this way you feel
that so not
here so here is the
top Force working on your
head and here is the bottom Force
working
on your
leg so after I do rich Kai
10 and I cut down on your hand that's
the top force on your head and then my
base in the
adashi is the bottom force on your feet
so now I actually have a Thro not it's
convenient for UK not to run okay now I
got to add this thing okay so I'm going
to rotate your Center and that's why I
don't cut straight
down but you're going to go I I'll do it
without Bing me you're going to go this
way
you maybe if you want to see over
here
my hand is not going to go
here my hand is going to go this
way so if we say run out of
it why can't you run out of it because
my
so Kos n is here you
see
Co it's
here it's not on my push but my is
this into that
leg okay
[Music]
front
leg
there you go that's the
pattern
[Music]
sorry
okay you you guys both did that
[Music]
one your here and then you going this
way right in the
lock in the lock with your
adhesion not
your and you don't have to go here do in
the lck you have it
body
I'll throw you you don't
have we're going to project you it's the
here still try to stand up do you think
stand up
okay okay and then try not to go
backwards try not to go
backwards in
the
don't cut it off you'll have to
strike
[Music]
Pro with
you pour over the tong fingers
down through the center from
there
[Music]
again that is not a pin for
GU so UK
should Ram be roll out of
that
okay
that's an acceleration
throw don't don't go off between reps
when you're when you're Naga you got
four reps to stay in a communion with
him even when you're not touching him
you keep going egocentric after each
throw you want to break you you clear
you disengage from the engagement alog
together okay let's
[Music]
go so that's giving him back his
balance here you see how you have them
then you go like this look where you are
stay there stay stay exactly there don't
move your spine don't push forward just
relax just
relax let me go don't move don't move
don't
move move your
arms you're pretty much standing
straight up you see that okay make a
fighting stance with your hands look
okay so you went like this and you got
him down then you bring him back to that
face he's perfectly up right again okay
you you have to tilt him he's going to
he's going to go knock back this
[Music]
way
boom this
way okay and then what am I going to do
step behind my that's right cuz this is
just an acceleration throw step out of
it step out of it every
time there you
go
[Music]
yeah so here is one part of the top
serving and here is the other
part and then don't don't make him go
that way start to spin him let's lift
this start to spin him got it
[Music]
he
make him
spin
thank stop waiting on the line
[Music]
he
C nope you're disengaged again hey
okay High
Mo
going I'm
moving I'm on the line then I move Then
I then I zone
out then on the line okay
already I feel all of that energy that
I'm going to feel I feel it already in
my body my body is matter so it has
energy so I'm moving moved off the
line
make it more
meditative don't keep going in and out
you don't resol them
like okay stay in it
wa th those are also momentum
all right so the throws we dealt with so
far here's my
dude
okay we do this kind of only one only
working on the top part so it ends up
being like
this and he starts to go past the Apex
of no return into a rooll but only
because he left his feet there
but if we're doing it right there's
there is a
force on the head and there is a force
on the
feet and then due to those two forces
spiraling themselves through space there
is this going on on his body okay he's
turning around once his it's not that
his body goes like this is it as his
body is gone it's turning
okay
that is one kind of
throw then you have
coka coka is working through something a
little
different okay you do use cou on all of
those throws but coka is a little
different here I'm not going to have a
visible
Force
either I either don't have it
here or I don't have it here in other
words there's not two forces work in
Topsy tury okay it's either one or the
other where does the Topsy Turvy effect
come from it comes from your energy what
you did with your energy
okay
so what is
key
is I'll do something let's say we'll
take the one that you just did there's
going to be a force here but there's no
Force here I'm not having my body there
okay
but as I continue to work this part as I
continue to spin the
technique your foot in its effort to
gain balance is going to try to move
back under your base Bas support so I'm
going to work on that eventually your
body's going to tilt do you see and then
you're going to try to put your foot
underneath your Bas of support so that
your back standing upright okay once you
put that foot out wherever you let's say
you put it here okay once you put that
foot down I continue this Force going
and now I will
project this Center at is spinning I
will project
it out okay so if you look at it from
the
top here let's say that's your Bas of
support
right
and you're
tilted I'm going to keep bringing this
part over here and I'm going to make the
whole base of support move out here I
make that go out there how by making
your Center go out that way okay and
then that way you can't keep stepping
underneath your Bas of support because
your Bas support moved in the opposite
direction from where you were trying to
replace it underneath your line of
gravity
okay so for example if I do the the
technique you did and he could run out
of
that
he just runs out of
it but if I C project I cut down here
and this cou projection I'll leave that
hand off this CQ projection is going
that
way so you have this hand coming around
you and then this hand going that
way so you now have an x pattern but
it's not with my body not on for example
here the x pattern was my my hand going
this way and my St going this way okay
this
time go this hand go
here this way this handle that way and
you have the
X so if you want to know what to look
for you have to feel
M on an acceler roll where ug decides to
just
roll his roll goes right where his foot
is no that's just roll here he's right
there his foot will always go right into
the
[Music]
r in a
k he's his foot as I said is going to be
the launching pad for his Center and
he does not get to roll by his feet I
don't know if you caught UK did you okay
so you you can do those any any
way see any any other
way it's got like this
though you keep
projecting even here you can do it
okay let's
go you got to ground you got to be able
to uh let his energy through you
otherwise it'll displace you you bounce
off of
him
[Music]
sh
he goes behind
[Music]
you
is the these are all
external we were on we went we moved to
CAG I showed you you can do ichai 10
without the x pattern the external x
pattern do you remember the last
technique I show okay so you got do all
all you can do all of these so I can do
T net where I have the one toy tury and
then the
physical other toy tury you understand
oh but you can still
do the same X just like you're going to
do K N right time kind of do what you
guys are
doing all you can still
do you see the difference
okay
[Music]
better first three not last one
good there you
[Music]
go
project try to hold your balance
okay
good
[Music]
clear don't give him back see he went
right back to standing
upright okay so
Ki uh the first thing you do in in G
okay in J is you want to start the
spiraling fighting geometry okay so
that's why you don't do this okay the
the second if I designate him UK got it
then that's 12 I will stand at six okay
just like uh I'm walking and that guy is
a oh I already start spiraling do you
understand so youa I don't stay at six
right away I start moving this
way this
way this way this way I go to one of the
corners
okay to get him to have to turn so when
do I go not before he starts as he
starts going you see I already
turn okay and what that's going to do is
this is going to set
up kazushi kazushi let's understand
kazushi I want his spine to tilt okay I
don't want him upright like this that is
why you don't ever do this and then he
throws there should never be a time Once
We Touch where he's standing straight up
okay okay uh doesn't let's say I'm going
to do shag and then he he wants to turn
inside turn this way you don't even know
how to do it but the other way you see
and look he again Let's ignore the grip
he's got Perfect Balance again okay he
should he should never be allowed to
stand straight up or going back to the
other technique we're showing you're
here and then you bring him back up
no he must always be
tilting so when I go to the inside and
he takes that turn towards me you see
he's going to I Can Begin the tilting of
his body much easier so first rule
kazushi starts before you
touch
okay second rule kazushi has his spine
tilting it's never upright and kazushi
is continuous to the throat
so it never tilts then goes upright and
then tilts again doesn't happen Okay and
then the way that I have it tilt is
through the center to Center or the I
keep going in your body okay so I'm not
only in his arms I'm not in his arms I'm
in his
body in his
body just like here I'm not only in his
arms
there right here in his
body in his body so I go down his body
goes down when I go to Project his
Center his Center Mo how catch
it you see it's in his body okay so I'm
going to start your
tilting but it has to
be from where you're touching me into
your Center okay so I'm going to do uh t
knet you guys are doing a lot of T KN
okay so I move at you but look I side
step
see I'm not going to wait
here and then go
out I'm going to side step and we'll do
it over here oh look he's tilting you
see and again uh
look not just here pulling his skin suit
down okay I'm I'm in in
him oh I move I do the yin yield there's
the Tilt stop there okay what I'm doing
in tenin go back one
step is first the iy adhesion is in his
palms and I've passed the eye cesion to
this arm at his neck okay so you're
going to take this away and now this is
moving
him we do it again back here
Sean I move towards him once he
engages I clear the line and now I'm in
his body at touch and I go to the Tilt
and now I'm here now I'm here okay and
now you do those X patterns that you
want the x pattern so his head's going
to go that way as I do the X
P that
way he never goes back
up or you could do it as the C you
net okay let's go